[Applause]
w K and G deduct station pilot to
Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive
it's Wednesday you shut up with bit with
a big dick and none but [__] heart
you understand me uncle Joey here
telling you how is the [__] it is out of
Wednesday morning February 1st 2017
understand me listen people gonna do
what the [__] they're gonna do and
you're gonna do what you're gonna do but
guess what you're the one that's gonna
come out on top you know why cuz you
prepared for this [__] day today's
the day [__] January's done it's
February 1st you're off and [__] run
and everybody's sitting there what is my
ship gonna come in what is my ship gonna
come in what is my ship gonna come yeah
Uncle Joe is here with the [__]
answer [__] it's a beautiful day
to be alive you're healthy you're alive
you got two feet get the [__] out there
you understand me listen you're sitting
there watching TV thinking about what am
I gonna make a move Charlie's in the
bush squat getting stronger by the
[__] Dave you know by the bush
squatting getting stronger by the day
you [__] slip and you understand me
but enough with the Tecate uncle Joey
what's going on with the [__] reef
for the day we're gonna open up with
[__] great white it's a hybrid it's a
hybrid it's just a fever Dominic get the
[__] out of my face I did it cuz it
smells good they gave me two grams for
free I took the [__] I don't [__]
with the TVs I'm an indica type I
[__] okay I want to see a devil
and his cousin if not don't come to my
house
that's what I'm talking about right
there
the mighty cloud of [__] joy
understand me podcast tonight seven
o'clock Nashville tomorrow night 8
o'clock Friday and Saturday two shows
Saturday and Sun Saturday two [__]
shows okay so what the [__] you think
you're dealing when I'm off from running
I've been doing jumping jacks it's 5:45
and the more they smoking reefer
drinking coffee eating nicotine dump
I got [__] hostages over here you
understand me anyway I sent my emails I
hung out with my [__] daughter I made
her some chocolate milk I love my wife
this boy had a little riding I made us a
couple cause you know me dog tip-top I
do more by nine o'clock than the [__]
Marines the army and the devil worship
was all [__] combined
look at that man you're sitting there
wondering what am I gonna do Trump Steve
banning who gives a [__]
smoke a bowl put a plan together and go
out there and [__] execute don't
worry about the [__] powers of Beast
this one did you worry about the [__]
man
the 20 years nobody wanna read worry
about the man everybody's heard about
the [__] man the only man you gotta
worry about [__] is the one hanging
between your [__] legs you
understand me that's the only man you
gotta worry about with a Steve banning
and the bad what's it got to do with you
what do you give a [__] what you gonna
do you take care yourself that's the
most important [__] thing número no
beard the Franky his self I was [__]
up for years I became a friend to myself
here we are in [__] periscope the
biggest TV station in the [__] world
and my flopping book you understand you
know why cuz we get to smoke reefer with
one another and that's a beautiful
[__] thing guess what I got right now
look at this scene offices this is the
Superman og this was Superman smokes
from the [__] Green Hornet and Batman
come to town because he don't need the
aggravation let's try it I smoked some
last night it was amazing a little
coffee shop I'm right for two [__]
hours you understand
what Susie called I come on the Dooley
people you gotta write you gotta fight
for your right to pawn it to worry about
[__] alright don't worry my mutton is
on my [__] you know what it is to
destroy ste can destroy that's what
you're worried about today how are you
gonna get ahead did you write your goals
did you yo get did you do your push-ups
then you want to come to me with these
[__] score is it I'm coming few words
college you can't do it now how you
can't do it understand no Tommy how you
can't do it tell me how we're gonna
[__] handle this you understand me
this is what needs to be done today you
want to be a [__] bad as you this is
what needs to be done why do you
[__] get me all fired up on a
Wednesday morning you know why there's a
lot of people laid down by Wednesday
they come out the gate [__] it Monday
Tuesday they come out they gave me a
little confused suck my dick Wednesday's
when I come out the gate thrown [__]
firecrackers and stars a deathly
understand me speaking of stars Church
of what's happened now AP 7:00 p.m.
tonight and then I hop on a [__]
midnight plane and you'll see me
tomorrow night
Nashville's Amy's eight o'clock let me
tell you something I've been in the
house for four [__] days I'm ready to
stab [__]
Thursday's the night you want to be
there I'm gonna come out with new Chuck
smoke [__] the whole thing WWE tights
you know me I'd take it to the next
[__] level anyway as you could tell
him storm to the gills
really happens what do you think I'm a
[__] Emil I gotta take two steps to
the real thing get out of here you know
I love you [__] don't take [__]
from nobody tell him more to suck your
dick what
what's it gonna do with you you ever
think about that you're gonna middle off
nothing confuse they gotta just stop
take a deep breath smell that fart and
go what is this got to do with money
nothing I still gotta make moves I'm
saying listen when you're sitting back
with 20 million in the bank laying there
[__] smoking to join a debt to little
Asian chicks rubbing your feet cutting
your toenails I'm saying you just hire a
guy just a bull [__] smoked his
entire chicken blow smoke up the [__]
all day that's when you come and say
Joey I don't need this aggravation in my
life but for right not today
listen grab your balls open your eyes
and get out there stop [__] around
it's wednesday [__] somebody's got your
lunchbox and you're sitting there like a
[__] move the law
get out there smoke some read one write
your goals call lead do whatever the
[__] you need to do you understand me
let's do one what do loads [__] to do
I'm gonna get too high
a [__] tent there I take a nap and it
blows my whole plan for the day you
don't need me doing it anyway I love
your mother [__] is wrong my heart don't
take [__] from nobody it's all about you
today they can all suck your dick bow
down to you understand me what what what
anyway Oh have a good day you know I
love you keep your eyes open write your
goals go for it that I [__] it and if
you don't make it today
oh yeah get in mañana that they didn't
get my mantle of being the higher
believe oh yo anyway I love you guys
stay black I'll see you tonight seven
o'clock the Voodoo Lounge the Churchill
was happening